يتلقى الامير الصغير جورج اغلب الانتباه
هذه الايام لكنه لم يتمكن من مجاراه احداث
الرحله الملكيه
الاخيره شخص شبه عار كان في
استقبالهم لكن هل هذه الطريقه المثله
لملاقاه ملك المستقبل نعم فهذه هي الطريقه
التقليديه للاستقبال في نيوزيلندا من قبل
راقس
الماوري فامير والدو استقلا بفرك الانوف
بترحيب تقليدي مع كبار
الماوي وفي لحظه من اللحظات اضطر الامير
ويليام الى خوض تحد بالتقاط سهم مع
المحافظه على التواصل بالعينين لاثبات انه
صديق وليس
عدوا وهذا يذكرنا باستقبال لورا بوش من
قبل جندي يرتدي سروالا قصيرا وكان من ضمن
الكتيبه النيوزيلنديه بافغانستان وهو ما
وصف
حينها بكونه خليطا بين رقصه الحضن ورقصه
التزاوج لدى طائر
الايمو وعاده ما يكون محببا رؤيه اندماج
الرؤساء مع السكان
[تصفيق]
الاصليين ولمره على الاقل لم يكن معطف
الدوق الاحمر الزي الوحيد الذي لاقى
اهتماما لكن ما الذي يفعله الامير بعد
مقابله شخص نصف عار يقوم بتعديل ربطه عنقه
صحيفه الديلي ميل وضعت العنوان الانسب
للحظه مقابله الدوقه لمقاتل نصف عارن اذ
كتبت انظري الى الامام يا كيت كرده فعلا
لتلك المؤخره
الممتلئه